right okay okay okay okay
here we go olive oils okay for the
vulnerable listen to me
1 tablespoon of walnut oil okay now you
like dresses on you that's it
three four right vinaigrette here we go
now from there half a lemon okay take
mine and oh dear right now come on okay
this is the exciting part yes greater be
very careful keep apple flat yeah
against the grater and grate here we go
now
Patsy may be slightly slow but you got
no excuse turn the air pull around great
I'm great
yes to the vinaigrette okay now from
there anybody risen yes you I don't like
my Indian I don't like a saltanat curry
you're doing a great job yes okay
everybody get hold of your baked beans
turn the tin upside down now listen to
me this is not a Delia cheating green
just take the bottom off okay stay with
me on this one okay really important get
rid of that get a bowl enter your beans
out that's the breakfast tomorrow
morning okay
pull your ring off yes wash no stay with
me Pat Sycamore just no music
now wash that ring out be very careful a
little bit sharp so here's the piece
that's toast where thank you whoa huh
now into the face for breakfast tomorrow
yes good my ring okay look you've got
the most amazing crouton for the salad
goat cheese yes